arbitrary Matrix m is that it's the trace of the square root of M * m dagger or equivalently the trace of the sare
root of M dagger time M you get the same value either way you do it and we can use that definition to simplify the
definition of the Fidelity as we have down here on the bottom of the screen and that's nice because it reveals that
it's symmetric in the two arguments we can also Express the trace Norm of a square Matrix matx M as the
maximum of the absolute value of the trace of M * U ranging over all unary matrices U which is not obvious but it
is true and that gives us another expression for the Fidelity so here we have three
equivalent definitions for the Fidelity and that's just the beginning there are several other equivalent definitions and
we'll see a particularly important one which comes from man's theorem toward the end of the lesson
okay so that's fine but what does it all mean at an intuitive level and why should we care about this
function to answer these questions it's helpful to consider the special case in which at least one of the two density
matrices represents a pure state if both states are pure then the
Fidelity is simply the absolute value of the inner product between the two Quantum State vectors and in some ways
this is a principal motivation for the Fidelity itself the absolute value of the inner product between two Quantum State
vectors is always a number between zero and one and it gives us a natural way of measuring how much overlap there is
between two Quantum State vectors and you can think about the Fidelity as being a useful and well- behaved way to
extend this way of measuring overlap from Pure states to density matrices if one of the states is pure
and the other one isn't necessarily pure then again we have a simple expression for the Fidelity which can be pretty
handy and that expression is shown right here the Fidelity has many interesting
properties and that's one of the reasons why people use it it has a definition that isn't really
all that nice but it's a very useful function never less and it's often very easy to use in part because of its many
amazing properties so let's take a look at some of them starting with the observation that the Fidelity between two density
matrices is always a number between 0 and one it's zero if and only if the states
are orthogonal meaning that the images are orthogonal subspaces or equivalently that the product of the two matrices is
zero and the Fidelity is one if and only if the two density matrices are equal every other case is somewhere in
between but intuitively speaking the closer the Fidelity is to one the more similar the states are or alternatively
the more they overlap the Fidelity is also symmetric I mentioned that a few moments ago it's
pretty clear from the expression that we saw for the Fidelity in terms of the trace Norm but it's an important thing to recognize
nevertheless next the Fidelity is multiplicative for product States meaning that the Fidelity between two
product States is always equal to the product of the fidelities between the individual
states here's a really useful property if we have any two density matrices of the same size
along with any channel that takes these density matrices as input the Fidelity can only become larger when that channel
is applied to both States so in other words in terms of the Fidelity channels can only make States
more similar to one another they can't make them less similar and finally for this list anyway
there's a pretty close relationship between the Fidelity and the trace distance between states which is defined
as half of the trace Norm of the difference between the two density matrices the trace distance between two
states connects strongly to how well we can tell them apart which we discussed in the previous lesson in the context of
State discrimination and the hellstrom Holo theorem while the Fidelity quantifies how much two states
overlap so although they're not exactly the same thing it's not shocking that there is a relationship between these
two quantities but in any case these inequalities which are typically called the fuk Vander graph inequalities make
this relationship mathematically precise and it's pretty important that there's absolutely no dependence here on the size of the system we're talking
about we can see this relationship a bit more clearly with the help of a figure if we have two states and we
locate the trace distance between them on the x-axis and the Fidelity in the y-axis then the corresponding vertical
and horizontal lines must intersect somewhere with within this gray region the most interesting region of
the plot by the way at least practically speaking is the upper leftand corner of the gray region in particular when the
trace distance is very small the Fidelity must be very close to one and vice
versa these inequalities get used very frequently and part of the reason for that is that we often care more about
the trace distance ultimately because it has a natural interpretation connecting with Quantum State discrimination
but the Fidelity has so many amazing properties that it's generally the easier one to work with and as long as we're in the upper left hand corner of
the gray region which is often where we find ourselves we don't lose too much by converting back and forth between the Fidelity and the trace distance so those
are some of the properties of the Fidelity there's lots more but it's a good start and hopefully the list is
helpful for beginning to develop some intuition about the Fidelity here's a nice example of how we
can connect the Fidelity to non-destructive measurements it's a very handy fact known as The Gentle measurement
Lemma suppose that we have a system x a state of X represented by a density Matrix row and a measurement on system X
described by a collection of positive semi-definite matrices let's suppose that one of the measurement outcomes is very likely to
appear if we were to perform the measurement on the state row just for Simplicity let's suppose
that it's the outcome Z Z that's very likely and in particular let's assume that this outcome appears with
probability greater than 1us Epsilon for some small value of Epsilon that we don't actually need to specify Epsilon
is just some small positive real number now we've described our measurement as if it were a destructive
measurement but we do know from the previous lesson that we could implement this measurement in a non-destructive way and specifically we could do it as
we saw in our discussion of Neymar's theorem and that works like this each outcome a appears with
probability equal to the trace of PA * row and conditioned on getting that outcome the state of X changes in